[Applause]
welcome to the uncensored comedy club
where no topic is off limits and we
laugh when do we all lose our sense of
humor well one person who hasn't is
comedian ricky gervais when asked on
twitter yesterday what he thought about
me interviewing the taliban official
spokesman he said i've lost all respect
for them it was a gag a lot of half
which didn't get the gag
why why have i lost the ability to
understand humor in a moment i'll speak
to one of the funniest men in america
great gut fell but first let's see him
in action
so it's 2021 and this monologue is on
the steele dossier like a birthmark this
story never ever goes away is that my
fault no i would much prefer to do
something on joe biden breaking wind at
the climate summit
that breeze was so hot greta thundberg
asked him to stand in front of a
windmill
[Applause]
but look that fart was the only honest
thing to come out of joe since he became
president as you know hillary clinton is
on her please don't forget me tour now
showing up on a late night show to crack
wise about the guy who shellacked her
like a driftwood sculpture in 2016.
yes trump is her meal ticket her free
bird her stairway to heaven she brought
chelsea because she's also unemployed
and bill wanted both of them out of the
house before his 5 p.m shows up her
name's crystal
well greg garfield george greg brilliant
to have you on piers morgan uncensored i
have a great time with you in new york
doing the five the show that you're a
superstar on your own shows on the
biggest show on cable in america
congratulations i want to take you back
to it thank you i'll take you back to a
quote that you said which i thought was
really pertinent to the time we live in
he said i became a conservative by being
around liberals i became a libertarian
by being around conservatives you
realize there's something distinctly in
common between the two groups the left
and the right the worst part of each of
them is the moralizing and i i thought
that was so pertinent to what goes on
now especially on social media
absolutely the uh
it the one of the greatest things that
the woke has done is that they've made
humorlessness hilarious
so what i was talking about is like
when you're around the left and they
they're so earnest and sanctimonious and
yet they get nothing done you drift away
then you get into the conservative realm
and you have the same kind except
they're they might be more religious
more moralistic in a different way and
you and you move into the libertarian
world but then even you in libertarians
you find some humorousness there but
what wokism has done for all of us and
has united up like left and right and
center is they have taught us how
humorlessness is the funniest damn thing
on earth they i mean the only reason why
my show was a hit is because of them
right cancel culture locism i don't have
to i don't really have to do that much
work peers which is kind of my goal in
life all i got all i got to do is go on
twitter you find the most extreme idiot
which is about 10 right of twitter and
then let them do the work for you they
do the heavy lifting with their you know
their twisted mindset i mean
it was hilarious last night i
interviewed the official spokesman for
the taliban and somebody tweeted ricky
gervais to say isn't it disgusting that
piers morgan's doing this and gervais
replied i've lost all respect for them
the taliban right of course it's just a
simple gang but absolute mayhem erupted
because most of twitter did took him
seriously and just thought he was
talking about you know
this was all disgusting and of course he
wasn't yeah
no it's a classic joke i mean you could
kind of see it coming it's like you know
i'd call you a dirt bag but i don't want
to insult dirt bags it's a it's so easy
but the problem with twitter
and it's it's part of abs you know free
speech absolutism everybody's got to be
there is that it's given an avenue for
the humorless yeah so they get on and
they'll actually go on and they'll see
the best the funniest part about twitter
is when people come on and explain the
jokes so i saw that ricky gervais tweet
the stuff that didn't bother me was the
people who didn't get the joke it was
the people that explained the joke there
was like a david like there was like
david bedeal
is that his name david badil yeah
he's british yeah he was like trying he
was like oh here's why this joke is so
good and then he goes on to explain it
and it's like oh god so you have in
twitter you have joke explainers you
have the humorless the humorless
contingent which is probably now
probably about 25
so but it's just what you have to live
with i find that to be in my opinion
more enjoyable
than the actual
legitimately funny people i mean without
wokism and without the humorlessness we
wouldn't have you know tidiana mcgrath
well this
this brings me to
two of my favorite subjects of humor
actually which is megan and harry who
are planning to come and hijack the
queen's platinum jubilee and i know you
find them a constant source of hilarity
as well they don't ever intend to make
us laugh they just make us laugh i got
it
i
love
that her woke cartoon on netflix got
cancelled there's a there's a great
story behind this the cartoon is called
pearl it's about a coming of age right
which is which is uh uh a code word for
nauseating you know self-involved tripe
so what happened is the this is my
favorite part so it's like a young
girl's
rise in social justice and you know who
you know who megan's cartoon is inspired
by
megan
she's made the car it's inspired by her
which is amazing and it but that's that
tells you everything that in the woke
world it is not actually about helping
people it's a disguise it's a virtue
signal that helps you that makes you
look good right and there's perfect
evidence of this because they never help
anybody but themselves and they never
fail they don't even change course yeah
they never meet they never mean it it's
never about actually anything but
enriching themselves and making
themselves look exactly i'm preaching
one thing
i resent england for sending your
second hand royalty to us
because now we gotta deal with this
to be fair you lot sent two women into
our royal family one of them led to an
abdication
and the other one has nearly broken up
the entire monarchy so with respect to
you america you're two for two and it's
not looking good
yes i just love the fact that they
thought that they were going to be
royalty here in america so there was an
assumption that when and they were
almost there i mean they were going to
get gigs everywhere there you know there
were netflix hulu apple tv everybody was
just going to give him millions of mills
and then they had to sit in a room with
them and realize my god they're vacuous
he's a nice guy apparently but i mean to
thoroughly evacuate she leads him around
on a rope and you know and it's like
that's it it that is the kind of sitcom
i want to see i'm telling you this is a
reality show i think i want to mention
too we do a nightly thing called the
world's gone nuts and i want to just go
into this one with you i'll clip my
fingers and [ __ ]
apologies for the american accent there
greg but this is such a brilliant story
it sums up the world we live in
scientists have declared that there is
sexism in the naming of parasitic worms
a team of scientists has concluded that
there were apparently uh
596 new species of parasitic worms and
of those only a hundred and eleven
eighteen percent honored female
scientists therefore they wanted an end
to this epidemiological nepotism and
cronyism and sexism in other words they
want more parasitic worms to be named
after women otherwise it's sexism
you know what i'm gonna go you know this
this
i'm so tired of ships being named after
women now they want our worms they want
our worms pierce
it's like by the way by the way has
anybody talked to the worms how do the
worms feel well exactly you know by the
way by the way if they had
if they hadn't named every parasitic
worm after women the women would have
gone nuts saying why are you calling us
all out to paris any worms
and how does a worm feel being called a
parasite a parasite is not a nice word
why don't you call them adjunctive
livers like or uh
no adjacent
adjacent survivalists
because i mean
parasitic it's just so mean-spirited
worms have feelings too i could talk to
you uh for a very long time i know that
you you made yourself the biggest star
on american tv because you just laugh at
all this nonsense it is all nonsense uh
and the world has gone nuts but thank
god you're here to help try and save us
greg gutville thank you i appreciate you
coming up
you got it thanks pierce
great guy